this Corona crisis as I call it you know
it's a smokescreen for something that's
been going on for years you know and you
know when I was your age I was in
Vietnam and I was flying for the Marine
Corps when my rich dad sent me a letter
saying watch out the world's gonna
change and the world changed because
President Nixon took the dollar off the
gold standard on August 15 1971 but back
then in the 70s being on an aircraft
carrier I didn't get that letter for
like six months that's how long it took
to get to me you know now you guys go
ding ding and you're there I mean the
world is really no world at all well he
warned me that the world would change
and I didn't really understand it at the
time and but that's when my curiosity
about gold and money and all this really
changed so today when I look at the
corona crisis but more the financial
crisis it's really really horrifying
because the financial crisis started
back in 1971 and the Rays I'm a rich man
today is because you know I knew
something was wrong I didn't know until
72 when I went I flew behind enemy lines
to go buy some gold and I didn't know
what goal was Americans to own gold in
1972 and I thought that was really
strange so my life brought me up to this
moment so I'm very happy to be talking
to you because the corona crisis while
serious the biggest crisis is the
financial crisis and your generation the
Millennials have been screwed I mean
big-time big-time I mean if you
understand how money is created money is
credit and debt that's all of this money
critten money
I mean credit debt and taxes that's what
money really is but they don't teach you
that in school so today the reason the
world economy is crashing goes all the
way back to 71 but what happened in 71
they could just make fake money and they
can keep printing fake money
this is the US dollar the US can keep
printing fake money for a number of
years yet and the only way they could
keep the economy expanding they had to
find people stupid enough to get into
debt so as you know one of the most
I didn't have this as a kid you know
it's called a credit card now everybody
has credit cards but they never teach
you how to use it why did it have a
credit card it's because they need more
money so they keep expanding the economy
they keep finding people stupid enough
to just get into debt the give them
credit cards and all this and say buddy
gives auto loans but I think the most
dastardly thing for your generation was
in 2009 when President Obama went to the
banks and said look we need to get the
students more into debt be under the
guise of you need to get a good
education the thing I've said before and
I'll say it again because some people
need to hear you're a generation this
thing call I was my cell phone didn't
come out until 2007 millennial
generation was given the most powerful
single tool ever given to any generation
and what do you guys use had this thing
for to Twitter to you know social I
don't know what you guys do with this
thing but I love this thing I mean I'm
I'm on YouTube constantly you know I
find the best teachers in the world out
there I mean I don't know why and I
would go to college because the best
teachers are on YouTube for free you
know I learned and it's not that the
teacher is the best the thing I love
about YouTube was I can get one person
says X and the got other sighs no that's
why and so I listened to both sides but
that's where your intelligence grows
because both sides have a point of view
I listen to both sides well if you're in
college Bella still one idiot was boring
you know I did not like school you can
tell I didn't want to become an employee
yeah I reckon the teacher says go to
school and get a job and I said
but I don't want a job you know and it
didn't make sense to me because I don't
rich - my poor dad was an employee he
was a good one but personally I didn't
want to become an employee but your
generation now must that's the
difference yeah must you don't have that
option the people that'll get hammered
that I'm wearing this paper right now is
taking me four months as a tough paper
it's called the brave new world and what
happened what this Korona crisis
represents is we're going into a brave
new world and I don't know if you guys
follow this but we're on the edge of
recession prior to January 2020 and just
said in prophecy I think I said become
in 2016 but I didn't foresee I started
prophecy in 1999 but I didn't foresee
quantitative easing and zero interest
rates I didn't foresee how desperate our
leaders are the Federal Reserve Bank the
Treasury Wall Street and even putting
students in debt I cannot believe how
desperate people are and I was just
talking to Mona and she was saying
everybody's raising their prices they
want a higher percentage of my books and
everybody's so desperate because this
world starting from 1971 is so deeply in
debt but they don't teach you that in
school so that's my concern
and so my prophecy which I started in
1998 I came true in 2020 the world's
never gonna be the same and I know this
people sitting at home right now saying
I'll go back to school and get my job I
mean I or I'll go back to work at a job
and many people you know in my world
they say was gonna be a v-bottom means a
crash comes I'm gonna go straight up I
don't think so
next one will be it goes a u-shape so go
down will go back to work it'll come out
slowly I don't think so and then does a
W goes down down I don't think so I
think it's gonna come down and go L so
the question I say to people is how I
and the people that work at Rich Dad
know we've been preparing for this time
so the Rich Dad
company is flush making a lot of money
better than ever before but we were
prepared for coronavirus 2020
yeah recession-proof is what we call
well I don't know poor recession-proof
but this is the difference is I'm now
prob now preparing for depression doing
I mean so we we made it you know Kim and
I and the team made it to 2020 and we're
flush with cash I have gold and silver
and all that like I said you sure told
me about Bitcoin but I didn't get it I
dig in a cell phone but anyway so I
would be preparing right now for the L
what if we go into a depression and
that's the thinking I am at right now so
I'm not Jane pushing the company we
cannot rest on our laurels Johnny I mean
a we're rich need to move on so that's
why I'm happy to be talking to the
Millennials because you guys have been
screwed the most with student loan debt
massive I don't know if you can
understand money but there's only four
point five trillion in base money and
one there is about 225 trillion in debt
that means it's only four point five
trillion for 225 trillion and debt
the machine's gonna stop soon you know I
don't know when but it's gonna stop and
when it comes to a stop that's when my
gold silver and Bitcoin will go through
the roof but I am prepared for it anyway
so your generation has the most powerful
tool ever created and the best teachers
are on YouTube and they're free and it's
important to go to school if you're
going to be a doctor a lawyer accountant
you know something like that but to be a
rich you don't have to go to school some
of the comments I get on my Twitter they
said well you know I tried to make money
and I lost so I'm never gonna do that
again
well that's a loser you know how many
times have I failed guys have seen me
you know like you guys know around me in
four years I got screwed and blue
tattoo just like everybody else but each
crash makes me stronger anti fragile and
that's where it starts and everybody has
that in them even if it didn't go to a
great school we all have a spirit well
have a soul we all have dreams we all
have desires but it takes time this is
like Tiger Woods it and become the
greatest golfer on earth taking one golf
lesson yeah I mean he lost he got he got
his hey he's he's gone down he's gone up
the greatest athlete I know but you know
he took his back out he wiped a more
stone and his wife took a 8-iron to his
SUV he's publicly humiliated he can't
play golf but he still comes back and
wins the Masters yeah that's what I'm
talking about we all have that in us
except if we have a bad attitude in our
mind so some of those comments I've seen
on my Twitter site as well you know I'm
not interested in money well your host
that little that those few words I'm not
interested in money well I don't want to
be a rich screws you for the rest of
your life if they took rich down away
and all my money away I wouldn't change
a thing I still be doing the same thing
a lot of people that lose their job they
change jobs but this is my job you know
this is my mission and that's that's why
I went to military school versus
university and I went to a Marine Corps
versus the Peace Corps you know I mean
that's just a different being so
everybody has that spirit inside of them
it's a lot of times especially when
times are good you don't have to call in
your spirit you just cruise and get a
good job we can make some money but
right now when you're sitting at home is
a good time to reevaluate life so if I
could show you this this is book number
two and the Rich Dad series you know
it's east hands for employee s B&I is
employee that little voice in your head
is saying I'm looking for a good night
same secure job with benefits if you
don't change those thoughts you stay
here no nothing wrong with it
except in the future because as you know
technology or AI and all this stuff's
going to make these guys less and less
important or you can be an ass and you
can say well if you don't want to done
right do it by yourself so the
definition of an S is there like a
doctor they can perform their job on
their own
or an accountant can do their job on a
home or a text a tech person can do
their job or an auto mechanic and do it
there's nothing wrong with it but it
limits them to this and these guys pay
the highest of all taxes so most people
when they they say I want to start a
business you know how am I start a
business they go here
so I started a business the trouble with
this site estar working for money and
money is taxed well as long as I don't
have a job I'm not taxed I think it's
pretty funny personally anyway and B is
big business that's Bezos and Gates and
now Zuckerberg and I is insider this
these guys are outside investor stocks
bonds mutual funds ETF I just wanted to
be an insider so if you're sitting at
home right now be thinking what do I
have to do to make these change it's
like I've said all the time you can be
here and you can be here you can be in
more than one place so when I'm sitting
around talking I'm actually all for you
know sometimes I'm working from my own
company when employable and company
right now I'm working on a project so
I'm self-employed doing it by myself as
an investor Mao is investing in big
businesses
I don't invest and small and small
businesses I make too many mistakes
there's two kinds of entrepreneurs small
and smart so I invest in smart
entrepreneur is not small entrepreneurs
a small entrepreneur doesn't have a
bookkeeper that's the first thing either
they have QuickBooks or quicken or
godmother that they have or they have
LegalZoom I'm out
you know I just they want to do it on
their own on this side I can't do it on
my own and in the world today this is
these guys are shark tank guys you know
Mark Cuban and all that so their mindset
is different but they also have the
experience to be here they're competent
you know I can say well I want to be
here but I wasn't competent for years
now I'm pretty competent because I have
a team it took years to get here if you
want more advice wisdom guidance from
other successful entrepreneurs on how
you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable
continue to believe and I'll see you
there typically you're gonna get it in
through one of three passageways